scivola sul ghiaccio si scivola sul
ghiaccio che carina che cos'è qualche
Altro indizio qua
hai trovato il cuoco non andare là sopra
non andare là sopra Wow Che [ __ ] questa
Escape Room Benvenuti su Anita Stories
che è pronto dovremo scappare dalla
Pasticceria
c'è il cuoco cattivo ma non è qualcuno
Guardate se Guardate lì potete Già
vederlo Guardate quella porta dovrà fare
Europa Ah ah ah pronti vi Mettetevi
comodi Prendi i Popcorn una torta una
torta ha portato una torta andiamo
andiamo dritta le felicissimo che stai a
quanti dolci ci ritroveremo qua andiamo
a mangiare allora da dove si va Anzi va
di qua allora prima dobbiamo parlare con
questo pasticcere ci sono qui c'è anche
un gelato Vai ciao ciao ciao ciao
Vediamo cosa dice il pasticcere siamo
stati intrappolati dentro la pasticceria
perfetto dobbiamo trovare una strada per
uscire da qua molto velocemente ok Beh
sì questo già lo sapevamo Grazie
comunque per l'aiuto facciale
Mi raccomando aspetta Io voglio vedere
un po' com'è questo Ah non mi fa passare
qua qua
c'è un frappè col gelato sopra lì ci
sono delle donne
Mannaggia peccato che in realtà non è
un'atmosfera molto allegra vedi come il
cuoco e anche non so se riuscite a
sentire questa musica
Vabbè ci sta bene perché siamo vicini
alla mia festa
la mia festa preferita qual è Se mi
conoscesse da un po' lo sapete Halloween
perché adoro le cose paurose
raggiungiamo Vitale perché ogni volta
che parlo con voi Vitale ne approfitta e
va subito a prendere il badge sapete che
devo prendere prima io il badge cioè
vince chi prende il badge per primo che
succede qua secondo te abbiano preso
vita
Stai attento ci sono questi Donald che
non sembrano molto amichevoli Eh le
ciambelle amichevoli cosa Ah Eccole qui
dentro c'è una ciambella alla fragola lì
che non sembra molto amichevole Ah
cioccolato da questa parte bellissime
però dai Vitale Prova a mangiarle ho
paura che loro mangiano Voglio vedere
capire poi te le mangi e anche queste
troom siamo diventati piccolissimi
Guardate che piccoli Sembri uno dei
bambini Oh mi piace il mio nuovo outfit
Tutto rosa come vedete gli orecchini
orecchini di oggi
non so se riuscite a vederli Forse con
il contrasto dei capelli si vedono
meglio
sono dei bicchieri di tè
simpatico
Rosa oggi Team Rosa proprio evitare il
team Celeste cosa stai combinando mentre
stai sulla strada per volare
però mi sono scongelato già un paio di
volte quindi non sono andato molto
avanti allora ti raggiungo subito No
sono tornato di nuovo Oh No anch'io Okay
proviamo a saltare solo nelle ciambelle
No scherzo Non ci riesco ah ah ah
E ogni tanto vengo sfracellato
al cioccolato poi appena passata Ciao Ma
tu sei stato mangiato dalla ciambella No
ho mangiato dalla ciambella No Ah quindi
non ti mangia guarda io sono qui vedi
Ciao ciao ciao ciao
avanti Sì sì Tu continua a parlare io
intanto scappo Eh ok Devo riuscire
a non essere preso dalla ciambella uh uh
che brutta Guardate uhh secondo me ci
mangerà prima o poi ci sarà una
ciambella che ci mangia finiremo con la
parte Marrone
aiuto oppure il pasticcere ci mangerà
Secondo me
Hahaha Come hai fatto fare qua
via via Okay okay
Ti aspetto qui al pasticcere alla
pasticceria AH AH AH AH AH AH AH aiuto
del pasticcere sono puntini puntini
aspetta ci sputerà ha detto Ma chi ci E
beh ah le ciambelle Qui si stanno
sputando a vicenda
pastondelle cioè alle ciambelle mancano
molto strana questa Escape Room va bene
Aiuto No vabbè dove sei Sei già passato
certo
distrarre dal cibo Questa volta non so
perché Forse perché abbiamo finito di
mangiare respiriamo per forza fare
l'escape Room prima di mangiarlo Calcola
però mi sta venendo da aver voglia di
mangiare una ciambella No no no
Ehi Vitale Dove sei Non ti vedo più ho
avuto un po' di problemi con questa
ciambella alla fragola mi stanno
sparando sempre queste ciambelle in un
altro stage Ah no sono in quello dietro
Ah ah ah sei tu in vantaggio
Evviva cadevo sempre nel buco della
Ciambella e quindi sfracellato ogni
volta
Beh io sono qua avanti e c'è un altro
antipastiere Vediamo che dice dobbiamo
usare quello che riusciamo per
arrampicarci sopra dovrebbe esserci una
bocca da qualche parte qui ora Brava
brava
questo eh sì eh una bocca Uhm Là c'è una
freccia la schiuma credo che dobbiamo
salire qua
solo per la scivolato giù
[Applauso]
[Musica]
No vabbè ok Ciao Ciao
ragazzi con i denti che rutta Abbiamo
fatto tante iscrizioni importantissime
Ma questa è una delle più strane eh
aiuto i piatti Allora ho capito qual è
lo scopo No aspetta un momento Cosa vuol
dire perché spariscono i piatti Ah
perché magari col peso cadono e quindi
ti devi sbrigare dai Sali su Comunque
dicevo capito qual è lo scopo del
pasticcere è quello di cucinare noi e
trasformare noi Ciao belli sono caduto
siamo finiti tipo nel magazzino forse
questo Ah
spatolato Eh dai questa Escape Room È
abbastanza facile per ora perché questi
pezzi cadono e quindi tu sei passata e
io sono passato subito dopo mi sono
iscritto perché qua il pavimento è
lavata meglio il pavimento dell'ava che
il laser Quindi quanto manca qui quindi
ci sono dei buchi Sì ma è abbastanza
facile invece dei laser io mi sfracello
Stef Come non detto
laser Io odio i laser Li odio dovrebbe
essere piuttosto Facile no Uhm
credo vedremo in base a quante volte ti
sbrace uh
uh wow
Io sì mi ha appena affettato un laser
devo aspettare Vitale perché qua c'è un
labirinto Altrimenti lui si perde nella
vita Ringrazio tutti grazie Lo prenderò
Comunque prima io Boh non lo so forse no
Ah ah Son passato proprio per un pelo
Dai sbrigati oh siamo tornati nella boxe
vediamo che cosa dice
perché lo chiama lavoratori di
panetteria
Vai dall'altra parte dell'incidente ed è
milkshake l'incidente del milkshake
Google Translate veramente
Oh adesso ho voglia di mangiare qualche
dolce che buoni vedi tutti perché
praticamente oh no questo Sarà
difficilissimo Wow che figata questo
schifo qua se ci riesco in Italia ci
riusciremo anche io no no no no no no no
no no no mi vuole mangiare
nonna no no no no no no no no no no
Aiuto
dall'altra
parte
Ho un'idea e io proverò a saltare in
continuazione
Wow Wow
ok Vediamo che cosa dice
questo deve essere il congelatore o no
si è scongelato il congelatore dovremmo
essere quasi fuori di qui Wow
Eh ma qua devo diventare nel ghiaccio no
forse devo scegliere il ghiaccio giusto
quale sarà io dico questo sì Ha
funzionato
No non era quello Allora forse di nuovo
questo
ora quello al centro di nuovo grazie
Ok l'ultimo tocca a te
Oh yeah sono passato Quello a sinistra
Oh Attento attento
[Applauso]
che tira fuori la lingua Ah ah ah troppo
divertente carinissima praticamente si
scivola sul ghiaccio quindi bisogna
sbrigarsi Allora meglio saltare Uhm è
molto difficile
aspetta fermo
la rincorsa Sì ho visto mi ha appena
sfracellato tutto da capo OK riproviamo
ci impiegheremo tipo un giorno e mezzo
per capire come fare a passare da qui ma
che ce la farò perché quando mi
sfracello mi cade la gonna devo capire
perché non mi avrai lingua del gelato
e sei riuscito
Mmm riproviamo aiuto
così almeno è più facile da gestire
perché sono più veloci quando arrivano
verso la fine hai capito
No non è ok
Basta
Mi avete scocciato gelati ora vi faccio
vedere io questa bravissima Ciao avanti
indietro così brava
sei mancato poco eh
Ci sei Ci sei brava brava brava brava
vediamo che cosa dice oh no non volevo
che per noi finisse qua
questo è l'ultimo posto dove dobbiamo
essere
in che senso che cosa vuoi dire che
moriremo qua vuol dire che ci cucinerà
il cocco cioè il pasticcere
se sono sopravvissuta Ecco il pasticcere
gigante lì ci riuscirà a prendere il
badge Vitale è già in vantaggio
[Musica]
è un sandwich di gelato sembra un
affamati se me lo chiedi stiamo attenti
Eh sì ce ne siamo accorti già da prima
Ah ho capito adesso Dominick
un po' malefici
dove dobbiamo andare credo che ci
mangerà il pasticcere è l'unica strada
vediamo
Ciao ciao Patrizia lo sapevo Guardate
che spettacolo siamo stati mangiati
Prima avevamo capito Dobbiamo trovare
una via d'uscita
piano piano piano piano piano
Qua bisogna andare molto diciamo perché
ho messo il cerchietto unicorno proprio
oggi il corno mi fa sfracellare Ah no
invece sono passata Okay vai piano Sì ok
ho capito nell'ultimo bisogna saltare
passato
fuori
Vediamo cosa dice evita l'acido dello
stomaco è pericoloso siamo nello stomaco
e ha mangiato i donut interi come al
solito masticarli Come hai fatto a
passare su questo pezzo di ferro devi
salire sopra Ah ok
salute Merlino ha starnutismo
e poi questo cosa sono
caramelle sembrano tipo non lo so Ha
mangiato delle bottiglie Ieri
chi ha mangiato uno dei suoi aiutanti
pasticceri Poverino
tutto intero il resto libro Ciao io sono
avanti Sì certo Vai vai pure tanto è
arrivato a parte preferita
Stiamo salendo
tutto Adesso è gigante il corpo di
questo pasticcere
di quelli in cui andiamo in genere
cosa ha fatto a scivolare così
Vitale è stato digerito dal pasticcere
Quello è il cuore lo sentite
Anita Sono in vantaggio Eh tanto poi in
quella parte lì di sicuro troverai
pianissimo Evviva Ciao ciao Vitale sono
in vantaggio io ti raggiungo
Ci siamo davvero parte preferita di
Vitale ciao ciao ciao
Vitale pure sempre qua in genere
dopo 10 milioni di sfracellamente dai
voglio vederti stracciatella aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto ci sono queste
baguette ah ah ah
primo sfracellamento al cioccolato Qui
no
[Musica]
essendo più sfracellerà di nuovo Vitale
Essendo la pasticceria magari questi
sono dei dolci
siamo
in quel nastro trasportatore che congela
i dolci capito
mi sono avvicinato cercando di vedere
gli sfracellamenti di livello sfregiata
Io comunque io sono riuscito a passare
Guarda Wow
mamma Siamo nei bagni e giustamente
Dobbiamo saltare su questi rotoli di
carta igienica giganti oppure sono
oppure Siamo noi che siamo minuscoli può
essere che siamo noi piccoli Sì Vitale
superato bene Ora giudichiamo dove siamo
ho un brutto presentimento
c'è un corridoio nero è buio da quale
parte Andiamo andiamo
a sinistra e vediamo che succede
qualcosa mi dice che ci inseguire sono
entrato in una porta
c'è una scala
e ci sono delle porte
ho trovato
penso che Aiuto Ho trovato il cuoco
aiuto il rumore stranissimo
fa molta paura eh Un cuore a te sta
inseguendo il cuoco No però l'ho visto
qui e fa molto paura
non mi ha preso
e io non so dove sono finita Ah Eccomi
tornata Hahaha
allora ho trovato questa stanza che è
meglio lasciarla stare perché c'era poco
dentro e mi ha preso lui in alcune
stanze
perfette Allora dobbiamo andare di qua
credo di sì o no
Come facciamo a saltare su quelle
destra sinistra destra Qualcuno ha
lasciato degli indizi
e Anch'io mi sono scotellato ho
dimenticato ok
ho trovato la freccia è un'altra quella
Ma quindi c'è un'altra uscita
Adesso ci provo dici
appena tornato Ok davvero uscite da
un'altra parte non lo so qualche Altro
indizio qua
hai trovato il cuoco non andare là sopra
non andare da sopra perché ti prende
Cioè o meglio riesci
a scappare Ma tu non riesci più a
tornare dentro Non so se si è capito
Cioè secondo me è successo una cosa
Siccome è strano che non ci ha inseguito
secondo me si è buggato il gioco lui si
è incastrato là sopra ma in realtà
doveva inseguirci questo è stato troppo
facile trovare questa uscita Quindi
secondo me dovevo seguirci
meglio così per noi non abbiamo finito
spero l'uscita Adesso vai anche ieri o
no c'è il codice Qual è il codice oh oh
oh Forse ci serve il codice che stava
dall'altra parte dei tuoi di quei vetri
che si rompevano mi sembrava facile
effettivamente Eh sì ok torniamo dove
c'era il ponte qua Allora allora
destra destra sinistra sinistra Sinistra
destra destra sì ce l'abbiamo fatta Ecco
il codice
8468 perfetto Te lo ricordi tu vero
perché io non me lo ricordo 8468
vediamo eh lo metto io sì 8 no aspetta
aspetta
Sì siamo scappati Oh aspetta aspetta
devo ancora tra le mura cioè Siamo
usciti fuori dalla Pasticceria ma siamo
dentro al cancello e c'è ancora il
milkshake qui che è stata per tutto
Dov'è il Belgio dove il peggio deve
evitare Dai dai no lo devo prendere io
Ciao
dobbiamo scappare da queste cose di
legno qui che Certo ci sono i Donato
malefici sono belli ragazzi attenzione
le ciambelle arrabbiate
piano guarda come è stata veloce altro
che piano senza fretta senza freni Fiat
Bravo indietro guarda quanto sta andando
velocissimo wow
no Il peggio è lì vicino Qualcosa mi
dice che il verde qua attenzione alle
macchine Mmm Uhm aiuto aiuto aiuto Ok
macchinina macchinina dove
sei
sto raggiungendo Vitale Ah ah ah C'è una
gara tra un bel Vitale una trappola Ehi
come nel torneo tre maghi adesso c'è la
pappa con Norvegia
Okay
ah ah ho preso prima Credo di averlo
preso prima io ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
adesso posso andare a mangiarmi tutti
quei donuts proviamo questi giochi
invece Dai dai figo aspetta quali
donazioni Mica abbiamo Donald's in casa
ti piacerebbe ma non ce li abbiamo
[Musica]
Comunque abbiamo collezionato un nuovo
badge ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video
Buona visione Ciao